l'armée française au secours donc de la
corse les militaires russes qui viennent
en aide à l'italie
huit brigades de virologues de médecins
de l'équipement médical était complexe
de désinfection sont attendus
aujourd'hui en lombardie la région la
plus touchée de la péninsule une aide
d'urgence décidée par le ministre russe
de la défense eric young ou à la demande
du kremlin
cuba dépêche également médecins et
infirmiers pour venir en aide à l'italie
ils sont 52 à partir dans les alentours
de milan dans cette équipe médicale
cubaine 30 personnes en lutter contre
l'épidémie du virus ebola en afrique de
l'ouest en 2014
écouter certains d'entre eux on va
travailler sans relâche à la prise en
charge et à la confrontation de
l'épidémie de kovy 19 avec les
professionnels de santé de ce peuple qui
est frappée de plein fouet par la
pandémie qui sévit sur cette planète
je me sens comme lorsque je suis parti
combattre et bollard très inspiré très
impatients de partager un peu de gains
médecine cubaine avec le monde à ces
personnes qui en ont tant besoin
la peur est inhérent à un être humain
tout le monde a peur de quelque chose
dans la vie mais la bravoure consiste à
affronter ce dont on a peur et lorsque
c'est une question de vie la peur est
réduite parce qu'en fin de compte on dit
celui qui meurt pour la vie ne peut pas
être un peu les morts